welcome to the show we have a terrific
program
and uh do i seem excited yes
and for good reason i am excited been
waiting for this day
we uh we have not had an audience
because of the quarantine
covid not had real people here
we're getting close couple days ago i
asked
my fans watching the show if they wanted
to be part of our real audience take a
picture of themselves
post it online and we would turn them
into cutouts here
at the largo theater yes professional
sports is doing it now we're doing it
and voila look at this we're starting to
fill
the audience over 15 000 people
have contacted us sent us their
photographs and we are as fast as we can
turning them into cardboard cutouts now
it's a process
it's taking some time but look we've got
a pretty good group here
this is pretty good yeah we have our own
little village
yeah we have an incredible village of
people and it's growing
this is gonna be a packed house by uh by
the next day or so this is amazing
what's happening
this is what america can do this is what
we should be doing not searching for a
cure
a vaccine making cardboard cutouts of
ourselves
that we can put in audiences that's the
answer
hey look here i'm going to do that on
thanksgiving
yes no family just cutouts sure why
should this year be any different
sorry andy pretty good slam though it
was pretty good slam
all right let's say hello to some people
in our audience that's carolina avia
got an aisle seat she came here early
and uh she's so happy to see me or
or she hates the sound of my voice and
is covering her ears next to her
well i think it's quite clear that that
is uh that woman is in love with me her
name's taylor
rudevy and she's just smitten and
uh of course upping the ante next to her
tomas jimenez
clearly having an orgasm um which
is something uh it's a common reaction
yeah to uh seeing this program
there's a benjamin tarr very patriotic
benjamin tarr good-looking american
right there enjoying the show
and next to benjamin tarr is a cat named
pablo
uh not doesn't seem to be that thrilled
with the show
pablo is waiting for something funny to
happen so far most content
more more
more mouse content that's what pablo
wants andy i think you're right
andy speaking of which who's that next
to you they they seem like uh a little
afraid of the show
this is my buddy jayden barnes why's so
nervous jayden come on
yeah well you're getting a little you're
getting a little handsy yeah yeah well i
mean i
you know i like this it's called fan
outreach right jake
huh let me there's a person in the front
row let's see if we can spot that guy i
think he's wearing a ghee
uh he's got his uh bear chested and he's
giving me a lot of tude
that is ian oliver and uh i believe he's
wearing a ghee
he is dressed for combat and he looks
like he wants to kick my ass
right across the street it might be a
bathrobe and he might just be a drunk
[Laughter]
back there andy do you see this person
in the final row yeah
the tux and i think this is kin of yours
andy i saw this guy yeah he does
we we are from the same sort of gene
pool
yeah of of porridge faces well who is
this gentleman uh what's his name
um chris cobby chris cobby chris cobby
well i like
uh chris uh you clean up real nice and i
like that you had the dignity to wear a
tuxedo
to our show no one's done that in 30
years he he has the richter family class
that's for sure
[Laughter]
anyway this is um this is really
exciting
the audience is starting to fill out and
i think in the following days you're
going to see this audience completely
filled with fans of the show who are
excited to be here
i think we're going to have a packed
house we won't be so lonely anymore
we're not going to be lonely at all the
important thing is if you want to join
in
all the fun go to teamcoco.com cutouts
send us your photo we'll put you in the
crowd this is exciting
this is us bobbing and weaving and
playing with the situation that we're in
right now man
i think jayden's face says it all right
buddy
[Laughter]
yes you too can be as happy as that guy
so get in on the fun this is this is
just a
a great way to show that we're all in
this together